it used to be that when someone made a
statement and then made another
statement that implied something
completely different we we had a name
for that we called it a contradiction
and it wasn't considered a good thing
you know not too long ago contradictions
could end political careers in this
country when Tim Murphy said publicly
that he was pro-life but then privately
told a woman to kill her baby he had to
resign from Congress Al Franken met the
same fate after he uh bought into the
metoo hysteria and then fell into its
crosshairs himself
but a lot has changed in the few years
since Tim Murphy and Al Franken were
forced out of Congress all of a sudden
contradictions are everywhere
particularly in the political world the
only way to ensure world peace is to
fund a war foreign policy experts tell
us we are a sanctuary state but we don't
want any more illegal immigrants say
Gavin Newsom and Eric Adams men can turn
into women gender studies professors
shriek euthanasia's Health Care the
Canadian government insists all of these
statements are contradictions but you're
hearing them all the time now
in Revolutionary periods this is nothing
new Mao even wrote an essay entitled on
contradiction a century ago Mal
understood well that contradiction
drives social change maybe the most
important contradiction that
revolutionaries must Embrace Mal argued
is the relationship between construction
and destruction
on their face these two concepts are
Polar Opposites tearing something down
means ruining it building something
means creating it if you want to build
something new you lay a foundation you
get to work you don't wreck what you
have
um that's how the bourgeoisie saw it
anyway but Mao didn't see it that way a
half century ago Mal famously explained
quote there is no construction without
destruction in other words there's a
logical relationship between the two
concepts creating a new Society one
totally unlike whatever came before
requires wrecking the old Society
creating new symbols requires wrecking
the old symbols Mao's teachings led to
of course tens of millions of deaths the
destruction of historic artifacts Mass
starvation
the last thing you'd ever want to do is
uh is or last thing you'd want our
political leaders in this country to do
is follow his ideology and try to
emulate it but that's exactly what's
happening
so this weekend in Albany the capital of
New York
we saw maybe the clearest example in
recent history of both construction and
destruction happening simultaneously
under the cover of Darkness at 5 30 in
the morning the city removed a statue of
revolutionary war hero and U.S senator
Philip Schuyler and at the very moment
that workers took Skyler statue away the
so-called progress pride flag was waving
in the background for the first time in
the city's history by the way so here's
what that looked like you can see it
there taking the statue away and then
we've got the um the multiple Pride
flags flying proudly uh as the statue is
hoisted away including the brand new
non-binary bipoc Trans whatever flag
they got all the flags there
now if that seems like a carefully
engineered juxtaposition it is it's
choreographed
to deliver a very clear message
Mao's disciples in the New York state
government know that if they want their
new flag to have any kind of legitimacy
then Philip Schuyler statue can't remain
you can't have construction without
destruction
if you want Revolution you can't
introduce a new Idol without erasing the
one that came before so that's exactly
what the local government did as
explicitly as they possibly could have
done it
if you're not trying to engineer
Revolution if you're just an average
person living in New York with
reasonable political views uh what few
of those May remain then none of this
really makes any sense what was wrong
with that statue exactly
as far as can be told here no one ever
bothered to ask a significant number of
New Yorkers that question
no one ever ran a poll on this at least
not one that we could find
there were certainly no Statewide
referendum on whether people actually
wanted Philip schuyler's statue to be
removed a few bureaucrats in New York
just decided to do it a few years ago
and this weekend they cut through the
red tape and they did it
a local news station did conduct a man
on the street style interview with a
couple of residents uh you know in the
city to get their perspective but none
of them could explain why the statue is
being removed even the people who
supported removing it couldn't really
explain why they supported it no big
surprise there but let's watch
it feels good the people have been
listened to and it feels good I'm just
happy it got taken down as the history
behind it is not something that should
be you know celebrated Mary Liz Stewart
is the executive director and co-founder
of the education center I think it's
time I was glad to see some action
finally taken on an issue that actually
percolated but about four years ago I
think she says the group of teenagers
spent a whole school year investigating
a whole variety of aspects that related
to the Statue not only the history of it
but why was it made what the cost was to
make it and what other communities were
doing with controversial statues that
related to enslavement Stewart says the
students wrote to Mayor Sheehan
recommending it be removed but not
destroyed rather to preserve it and use
it for educational purposes one of the
things that was very important for the
teens about moving the Schuyler statue
was the fact that from their perspective
City Hall should be a place that's
welcoming to every everybody in the
community and it was hard to say that
was the case with Phil you know standing
there
yes a century-old historic artifact
memorializing a revolutionary war hero
was not only taken down it was taken
down at the behest of a group of
teenagers
and the primary reason as we heard in
the clip is that the absence of the
statue will make City Hall more quote
unquote welcoming
but welcoming for who if the standard is
that any unwelcoming statue needs to go
then why exactly can't we destroy the
Monument of George Floyd that sits for
example outside City Hall in Newark
but George Floyd didn't own slaves you
might say well that's true all George
Floyd ever did was break into a woman's
home with five other people hold a gun
to her chest robber in front of her kid
and then getting out after getting out
of prison all George Floyd did was take
enough opioids and meth to kill a horse
before trying to rob a store and
fighting with several police officers
despite all that you're not allowed to
even criticize the George Floyd statue
you lose your job if you do
under the new rules George Floyd's
statue is welcoming the Revolutionary
War General is unwelcoming you
understand that well probably you don't
understand it but then you aren't
supposed to understand because part of
the point Behind These arbitrary
decisions is that they make no logical
or moral sense
you're meant to go along with it whether
you understand or not we we might ask
why but the powers that be will treat us
like we're children
and there are impatient parents because
I said so they respond Congress once
again allowed itself to be pushed into
appeasing the administration and raising
the debt ceiling for the 79th time
Paving the way for continued Reckless
spending and further devaluation of the
dollar as our national debt continues to
Skyrocket how are you protecting your
savings Times Like These are a great
reminder to diversify a portion of your
savings into gold and you can do that
with the help of Birch gold they're who
I buy my gold from so do thousands of
other concern Savers Birch gold will
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
into an IRA in Gold you don't pay a
penny out of pocket when currencies fail
gold is a safe haven how much more time
does a dollar have left think about that
well you can protect your savings with
gold Birch gold as an A plus rating with
a Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and you can find out why
if you text Walsh to 989-898 and get
your free info kit on gold again text
Walsh to
989898 it's also contrived Philip
Schuyler is an iconic figure of the
Revolutionary or era he's one of the
reasons this country exists today
multiple towns and forts are named after
and in New York
and curiously no one had a problem with
him until very recently
ten years ago in an article the Albany
Times Union described Skyler this way
quote Philip Schuyler was a leading
American statesman and a key General in
the American Revolution who served at
the pivotal Battle of Saratoga he was
named a representative to the First
Continental Congress of Philadelphia and
an adviser to General George Washington
who stayed at schuyler's mansion in
Albany
the Times Union went on to describe
Schuyler as quote instrumental in the
victory of the American colonists at the
Battle Saratoga in the fall of 1777 the
turning point of Revolutionary War
residents of Albany fearful that their
City might be occupied by British
soldiers instead celebrated an
unexpected victory at Saratoga it was
the first major win for the colonists
and the residents of Albany rang church
bells fired cannons roasted an ox and
gathered around a large bonfire Schuyler
returned to the city of his birth as a
hero now you can read the whole article
still on the times Union's website from
2013. there's not a single mention of
slavery or slaves in the entire piece
but guess how the Times Union the same
newspaper describes Skyler now
here's a recent article from the paper
from this year quote while noted as a
politician and Revolutionary War hero
Skyler enslaved over a dozen people at
his Saratoga and Albany homes
the Times Union of 2023 goes on to site
and this is not a joke a report by five
high schoolers who say that Skyler is a
bad man and his statue has to be removed
that's the report you heard referenced
in that news clip as well
so here's how the time Union describes
the findings of these high school
students quote
the report titled what to do with Phil a
2022 report from The Young abolitionist
leader Institute was created by five
Albany High School students who met
between October 20 2021 and June with
two adult facilitators while the report
notes Skyler's accomplishments as a
Revolutionary War General and politician
his legacy is still marked by owning
human beings it says
this is also the report that the Albany
government relied on to justify removing
the statue
facile does not begin to describe this I
mean in the 18th century no one had the
same attitude towards slavery that we do
now even the people who opposed it which
relatively few people did back then for
on a global scale
it's not surprising that a bunch of dumb
arrogant kids would lack the proper
historical perspective and think
themselves qualified to pass moral
judgment on historical figures who live
250 years ago but that's where adults
are supposed to step in
the problem is that there aren't very
many adults left in this country
what's really going on here is that
Skyler like Jefferson Washington Lincoln
Teddy Roosevelt all the other historical
figures who've had their monuments
destroyed
is that uh you know these are heroes of
a different Nation
one that the city of Albany considers to
be a foreign enemy basically
and they know they have to erase them if
they want their Revolution to succeed
the Biden Administration understands
this as well obviously look at this
grotesque display currently hanging at
the White House they put this up over
the weekend and that is a pride flag
hanging on the White House and it's in
between two American flags there are
similar displays all over the country of
course at 30 Rock and so on but
putting this flag at the White House
just like the flag at Albany City Hall
has particular implications
and you know most conservatives as that
was uh put up over the weekend reacted
to it
and we're saying that it's horrific and
it's evil for the White House to not
only fly the pride flag but to give it a
place of Primacy in between two American
flags
and of course it is both of those things
it's horrific and evil for sure
but what they don't understand is that
the White House
is also properly representing its own
Nation
which is not our nation
okay we are two nations in one there is
the old United States that conservatives
still cling to and cherish and there's a
new country with its own flag its own
Traditions its own Heroes and
foundational myths Etc
that's the nation that the Biden regime
the media Academia Hollywood all speak
to and represent
why do you think that the city of New
York took down Teddy Roosevelt's statue
recently I mean liberals used to love
him he was one of the greatest
presidents this country ever had he
broke up big monopolies he was well read
he saved the middle class he established
national parks he was a Pioneer an
explorer
they took down Teddy Roosevelt's statue
in New York for a specific reason which
was to replace it
instead of Teddy Roosevelt New York
recently put up the horned statue of
Ruth Bader Ginsburg
and that's now happening at scale the
nation we had before is being replaced
it's not just that demographics are
changing though they are the activists
who are leading this revolution like all
totalitarians understand that to take
full control they need to erase our
shared history
and they're executing this plan this
plan right in front of us
and plain sight as obvious as they
possibly can
while conservatives are debating the
proper positioning of the American flag
in relation to the pride flag of the
White House the government is going out
in the middle of the night and
destroying the symbols they don't like
they're not asking your opinion about it
they're just doing it
and with that in mind it's not hard to
wonder like what else will they take
away before you even realize it a lot
more than statues
soon the government may be able to
kidnap your children if you don't
subscribe to The Cult of gender ideology
that's happening in Canada it's been
happening for years now and that's an
actual bill in California right now
which we'll talk more about in a few
minutes but they will label you a child
abuser and put you in prison for wrong
think so the state could raise your
child
that's the ultimate goal of this push
for inclusion quote unquote which of
course is fundamentally about excluding
anyone with traditional views and in
particular religious views
the totalitarians running the government
like all totalitarians throughout
history are obsessed with using their
power to make future Generations
subservient to their rule that's the
reason they're sponsoring Pride parades
that expose children to deviant sexual
fetishism and everything else
that's the reason they're destroying and
replacing everything they can
it took the the single deadliest famine
in world history to stop Mao
what will it take to stop the revolution
that's taking place right now in this
country
and the longer this goes on the longer
sane people stay quiet and watch as it
all happens
the more likely it is that unfortunately
we're going to find out
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed